استراتيجيات وحرب روسيا على اوكرانيا بدات
تاخذ منحا مختلفا عن الاشهر الماضيه وتلك
لا تقتصر على التقدم والتراجع في ارض
المعركه بل تتعداها الى تحضيرات من
الجانبين
اوكرانيا تطلب مزيدا من الدعم الغربي وزير
خارجيتها متروكوليبا يدرك التفوق الروسيه
في القدرات الصاروخيه فيطالب بقتل صناعه
الصواريخ والطائره بدون طيار بضربه عقوبه
جمعيه كما قال
المتحدث باسم الكريم
بالسلاح لا يغير الاوضاع على الارض
كاسكو بذلك الى طلبك كيف تزويدها بدبابه
ليوبارد اثنين فيقول ان هذه الدبابات
ستحترق
روسيا تقرا استمرار تدفق السلاح على
اوكرانيا بانه تكتيك هجومي وليس دفاعيا
على الاقل في شبه جزيره القرم قاعده
الاصول الروسيه على البحر الاسود للمكان
اهميه عسكريه واستراتيجيه بالغه لا تسال
موسكو غير قادره على تحيده بالكامل عن خط
القتال يقول حاكم
ان انظمه الدفاع الجوي واسطول البحر
الاسود
اسقطت ثمانيه طائرات مسيره لدى اقترابها
من المدينه في هجوم استمر ساعات وليس
الاول من نوعه
يا ترافق ذلك مع وصول 100 جندي اوكرانيا
الى قاعده عسكريه امريكيه في اوكلاهما
للتدرب على استخدام منظومه باتريك وفي وقت
تتخوف كياف من تحضيرات الروسيه لضربه اوسع
انطلقت مناورات بين روسيا وبيلاروسيا
تدريبات تقراها كيف بانها خطوه لاعاده
التجميع القوات الروسيه او لنقل مزيد من
الحشود العسكريه الى الشرق
مواقع مدنيه
انا بخمط فتبقى في دائره الضوء مع تقارير
بسيطره القوات الروسيه على مواقع جديده
للجيش الاوكراني جنوبي المدينه وتهاجم
الضواحي الشماليه وهما ينفيه الجيش
الاوكراني ويتحدث عن خسائر الروسيه
الفادحه في بخمه ومحيطها